who owns the Brazilian Amazon that's a
more complicated question than you might
think this 4 million square kilm of
forest has become the wild west of land
grabbing and that's a problem if you
want to save
it some 42% of the Amazon is reserved
for nature or indigenous people much of
the rest is privately owned but ranchers
and miners often stake private claims
that overlap with public or protected
land just on the edge of the trans
Amazonian Highway between umita and
labria you can see behind me um the
forest is burning some of these fires
are illegal some of them are legal given
the confusion and lacks enforcement of
the legal system in Brazil it's often
very hard to tell there are 22 different
Federal and other government agencies
that register land claims in the Amazon
they don't talk to each other so who
owns what isn't clear in this chaos
deforestation thrives the there's a big
incentive for land owners to create
facts on the ground chop down trees and
hope that someday the federal government
will grant them title to it local
officials often tolerate land grabbing
because Miners and cattle Farmers
generate more money than trees do the
previous president Sher bolsonaro didn't
care about deforestation the current
president Lula does since he came to
power deforestation has fallen by
50% Lula being the new president it
means hope Lula is now trying to create
one coherent system for registering land
to clarify who owns what this is an
essential first step to bringing the
rule of law to the Amazon without which
the rainforest cannot be
saved